about partisan transfers thanks everyone
so this is joint work with Amir Glo
Burson from Tel Aviv and David Sonntag
and Sheffield room from NYU and don't
let the title fool you okay so it's true
that we were motivated by applications
and machine learning it's true that it
appeared in ICML a machine learning
conference but the secret is that
actually most of this work is really
theoretical results about what I think
is a very appealing combinatorial model
which actually has a lot of open
questions that I think many people in
this room are really well-suited to make
progress on so I'll try to highlight
those opportunities as we go through the
talk all right let me just le say one
slide what were we motivated by a
machine learning side and what the heck
is structured prediction anyways some
structured prediction you know we're
given a bunch of objects and we have
information about the relationships
between these objects you want to use
that information to predict labels for
all of the objects at one time in one
batch we want to be smarter you want to
be more intelligent than just
independently predicting each of the
objects without any of the relationship
information between them so one
canonical application and the one that
really motivated us was from computer
vision specifically image segmentation
so here the objects would correspond to
pixels the relationship information that
could be as information about adjacent
pairs of pixels what you're trying to
predict is for example a segmentation
into a foreground in a background so for
each object you're giving it a binary
label is it in the foreground is it in
the background and all but it's easy to
imagine that you know using information
about adjacent pairs of pixels allows
you to do much better than just
predicting looking at each pixel
separately okay lots of other
applications like a natural language
processing you know sometimes you want
to you have a sentence you want to infer
you know what is the role of each word
in the sentence and you can imagine you
might want to use information for
example about consecutive words above
and beyond just predicting each word
separately okay and then I guess one
final comment you know on this slide
just to clear up any confusion so in
theory I could be to science there's
been a there's been a lot of you know
really nice work lately on the interface
with machine learning a lot of the works
that you may have seen have really been
about the complexity of learning a model
so maybe in a supervised setting given
label training data or in an
unsupervised setting
unlabeled data try to compute a model
which seems to fit the data and that's
not what we're doing okay
we're assuming that we already have
learned the model okay so we're gonna be
assuming a generative model on the input
we'll just take it at face value and the
problem will just be inference given
this model that we believe what actually
are the labels of these objects and of
course if you're trying to predict you
know a bunch of pixels at once a binary
labeling for each even the inference
problem right that's an exponential
number of outputs and can be quite
interesting okay all right so let me
jump into the model okay not really the
model this is sort of a silly version of
the model but let's start here anyways
so you're given a graph and you know
this graph so this could be for example
a grid in the image segmentation
situation where each edge denotes an
adjacent pair of adjacent pair of pixels
there's a ground truth binary labeling
so this would be for example the you
know real segmentation of the image into
the foreground in the background so
that's gonna be X labels each node 0 1
that's what these red and blue colors
denote this you do not know okay this is
what you want to compute okay so if you
don't know X if you don't know the label
and what do you know well suppose I gave
you you know this pairwise relationship
information okay so for each edge of the
graph suppose I told you whether the two
end points belong to the same had the
same label or whether they had different
labels so a plus here means that the
labels at the end points are the same
minus means that this should be
different the goal then is you know
given this information on the edges
recover this secret binary labeling of
the vertices so this seemed like a hard
problem
not be unique but it's unique up to a
relabeling of the two colors yes so this
is not our problem
okay so you know if the graph is
connected you know just guess just color
some vertex arbitrarily like maybe you'd
color that one green and now you're just
propagate across the edges right given
that that's green you know these are red
given that all of these are pluses you
then know all of these are red and so on
if you guessed wrong then you get the
ground truth except with the order of
the colors reversed and that's perfectly
fine for our purposes I said this was
the silly model yeah so the silly model
there's no errors and it's an easy
problem okay but hopefully everyone's
clear at least so far so the interesting
problem is when you want robust recovery
results so where I don't actually give
you the parity of every edge but rather
I give you
noisy parodies okay so the model is
going to be that on each edge
independently with probability P you get
the flipped version of the actual period
okay so I think compared to the previous
slide I flipped these - these were
minuses and other pluses and these used
to be pluses and now they're minuses
okay so those are the four miss leaving
edge labels okay so given noisy edge
parodies the goal remains the same you
want to recover this binary labeling of
the vertices or if you can't do it
exactly you'd like to get as much of the
unknown label incorrect as possible so
many of those vertices correct as
possible okay so that's the model so
what do we want so the objective we're
gonna look at is we're gonna look at
minimizing the worst-case expected error
by error I just mean the hamming error
between the output of an algorithm and
the unknown ground truth
okay so just the number of vertices that
are misclassified by the algorithm so
the algorithm is just a mapping all
right so the graph think of the graph is
fixed it takes as inputs the plus/minus
labelings on the edge and it outputs a
binary labeling we're gonna take the
worst case over the unknown ground truth
X D of X here denotes the distribution
on inputs on plus/minus labels given
that the ground truth is X L is a given
set of edge labels this is the output of
our algorithm on those edge labels and
this is the error with respect to the
ground truth okay so like like a lot of
the work in sort of beyond worst-case
analysis this has sort of a hybrid flip
or Interpol it sort of is in-between
worst case an average case analysis
worst case over the ground truth with an
average case over the distribution on
inputs given the ground truth that's
what we're gonna be after any questions
about that it could I mean we're not
gonna have a reason to do that but it
could it is yep we'll get to that if it
is the one thing I want to point out
right now is that in correlation
clustering the objective function is
with respect to the edges so there is
not you're at least in the version of
the problem often studied in like
approximation algorithms there's no
ground truth there's only data and you
just wanna get as many edges correct as
possible here we don't care about how
many edges we get correct except in as
much as it leads us to a labeling of the
vertices which is accurate with respect
to the ground truth so it's kind of a
difference of viewpoint compared to the
usual approximation algorithm sure but
again so the way correlation question is
usually done in approximation algorithms
is different there's with a different
objective I just wanted to make that
point in if you're a computer science
book okay and so as we'll see the
algorithm will be correlation clustering
so there is a very strong connection
okay questions yeah Roby
they know wolf days the graph and thing
it was fixed so we're gonna be
interested in results that vary with the
graph G okay so there will be some bad
graphs there will be some good graphs
and the whole point of the theorems will
be to understand which are which okay so
think of the graph G is fixed but
arbitrary and then what the graph is
will shape the results in interesting
ways
alright so that's fine so this is our
goal you know you want an algorithm with
minimum expected error but well I mean
what are the theorems going to look like
right so for a fixed graph there's only
a finite number of these algorithms and
one of them is best you know so what
okay so what we want to prove well two
things so first of all you know even
ignoring computational efficiency issues
just information theoretically what is
the minimum possible expected error that
is achieved by any algorithm not
necessarily efficient is it zero if it's
not zero what is it how does it depend
on the parameters of the problems of the
model okay what are the parameters of
the model the graph G and this noise
rates P okay so both of those might play
into what is the minimum expected error
possible we want to understand that now
of course computational efficiency is
also interesting so ideally in a perfect
world you'd like a polynomial time
algorithm which gets minimum you know
worst-case expected error as small as
the information theoretic lower bound
that would be sort of the holy grail
here okay and hopefully that arrow is
pretty close to zero this small
so you still will probably have this
sort of flipping that's right yeah
that's one way to think about it I mean
the paper has a more general model you
also get some signals from the nodes and
then you can use signals from the nodes
to tie break between all the elements in
your list but for this talk think of it
as list decoding there's always going to
be really two outputs you know one and
then the end this sort of flipped
version of it and then some downstream
user can figure out which one is
actually the foreground which one is
actually the background it was an error
as a just a lower bound yeah sure so
okay so what I really mean is the error
of the better of the labelings output by
the algorithm and the flip of it I guess
I want to be totally precise that's what
this should say yeah good so I realize
this is a new model for many of you so
let me let me build your sort of
understanding of this model and how it
might work by an analogy to a pretty
closely related model that I think many
of you have seen at some point namely
the stochastic block model so there's
been a ton of work on the stochastic
block model over the past few years
sometimes this is called the planted
partition model or it's called the
community detection problem so for
example Aravind in on Monday his talk
was about recovery in stochastic block
models so the simplest version of this
would just be like a planet bisection
problem okay so you can imagine that
there's n over two people or a number
two vertices that belong to one
community a the other end over two
vertices belong to some other community
B you don't know what that partition is
you want to figure it out and what
information are you given well you're
given random edges and the trick is that
the density of the random edges is going
to be higher inside the communities a
and B then across a and B okay so this
will be relatively sparse compared to
the edge density in here and in here and
then it's plausible you could
reconstruct who's in a and who's in B
given those edges okay so that's that's
recovering the stochastic block model
and this bears a lot of resemblance to
the structured prediction problem okay
so the biggest difference is there isn't
really an arbitrary
gee and stochastic block model there is
a set of vertices okay but remember in
the structure prediction problem there's
a graph G like the grid and you only get
pairwise information about the end point
about two vertices that are the
endpoints of an inch okay and it's the
cast a block model every single pair of
vertices you may or may not have an edge
so you get a noisy signal about every
pair of vertices in the stochastic block
model so if you like think of that graph
G as being the complete graph in the
stochastic block model not something
like a grid okay so that's the first
biggest difference but otherwise what
else we have an unknown binary labeling
okay who's in a and who's in B we get a
noisy version of edges and we want to do
recovery okay the other way in which
it's different which you know I want to
emphasize less is just that the the
noise is asymmetric in the stochastic
block model where's it's symmetric in
the structured prediction so recall in
the model I presented for every parity
it doesn't matter if it's a plus or a
minus in the ground truth it gets
flipped with the same probability P for
the stochastic block model okay so what
would it mean to have like no noise no
noise would mean I give you two cliques
one click on a another click on B and
they're wedges in between but there's
noise a lot of the edges inside a and
inside B are going to be missing and the
graph you get and some of the edges
between a and B are going to be presents
and the usual parameter regime studied
in these models there's a very high
error rates inside a and B okay so you
don't get a clique you get something
with much much fewer number of edges but
then the error rate is very low across
the cut okay so with no noise this would
be empty but you don't allow too many
edges here in the usual
parameter regime okay so those are the
two big differences so the similarities
are you're again given edge information
want to recover the son non-binary
labeling and the objective function is
the same you want to get as many of the
vertices right as possible the big
difference is that the predictor the
structure prediction model includes a
graph G a a comet or object so theorems
about the stochastic block model what
are they parameterize by well what's
available what are the knobs you have in
this model you have the edge density
inside the communities and you have the
edge density between the communities
maybe you also have like the number of
clusters if you have more than two
clusters so all of the theorems are
about that you know
in terms of these numerical parameters
of the edge densities and the number of
clusters
whereas in structured friction there's
this extra parameter a comet or object
the graph so we're gonna have theorems
which actually depend in an interesting
way on that graph that's the biggest
difference good so let me show you that
the graph matters okay there's some
graphs that you're just sort of hopeless
okay specifically the path graph is
going to be hopeless
so take G to be a to be a path graph
with n vertices with in going to
infinity and you want to do recovery and
let's suppose I'm going to be a really
nice guy I'm even going to give you some
advice about what the ground truth is
I'm gonna promise you it's a bunch of
zeros followed by a bunch of ones the
only thing you don't know is the switch
point where it goes from zeros to once
that's what you're trying to figure out
okay so if there was no noise at all
like these would be your edge labels it
would be all pluses except for a single
minus indicating to you where the switch
point is okay but what are there's noise
and let's say not that much noise so
like well sub constant noise they log n
over N okay now what's the input going
to be well you're still probably going
to have that correct - indicating you
the true
flipping points of the labeling but
you're also going to have log in extra
minuses that you know are just corrupted
parodies so you're just gonna be faced
with a path with roughly log n minuses
you know roughly equally spaced between
the two you know one is the correct one
you don't know which you have to guess
so linear error is going to be
inevitable okay so any any algorithm is
going to have expected hamming error at
least say 0.25 times N and miss regime
okay so that's a bad graph okay even as
the graph grows large and the noise rate
goes to an 0
you're the best possible expected error
is lower bounded by a constant times n
independent of the noise rate
as opposed to this constant there's one
over N yeah I give you that too this way
this way you can say with high
probability you know how many minuses
there are but it's not important so it's
not important yeah
I just find it helpful I feel like with
this regime I can almost think of it as
a semi deterministic object which just
for me is helpful but you don't need it
not good other questions
so this example of a bad graph a path
where you actually cannot recover this
unknown ground labeling given these
noisy edge parodies well God is kind of
excited about the problems when we
started running experiments and we were
looking we started with a grid and we
were curious about the grid you know
because of the applications because it's
sort of the first graph you think about
if you're thinking of computer vision
applications also there's some
technically interesting aspects of the
grid like it's not a good expander for
example and so the picture here you know
so full disclosure this is a slightly
more general model than what I'm
describing in this talk this also has no
noise but forget about that it's also a
slightly different algorithm and what
I'm gonna talk about but you know
qualitatively you know the points I'm
making remain valid and so the point
here is this this has a p-value this
case with a noise rate of 8% 8% of the
parodies are getting corrupted and this
is and so then what do we do we take a
bunch of samples
okay so we've fixed the ground truth to
just be everything as zero now we you
know corrupt edges at random we do that
a thousand times you run our algorithm
each of the thousand times and this was
the average number of times we made an
error in a given pixel everybody get in
a given vertex for a 20 by 20 grid and
the only sort of point here is that the
error you know the average error is
tracking the edge noise you can't really
see this because I'm just showing you
one data point but if you continue this
experiment with different choices for
the edge noise you see the hamming error
expected hamming error drop it seems in
proportion with the edge noise okay so
here we were at least empirically on 20
by 20 graphs getting the kinds of
approximate recovery results we wanted
we weren't getting a completely correct
and you you don't expect to as we'll
discuss but this is much much better
than the path where you just stuck by
say 0.2 by 25% error no matter how big
the graph gets
yeah
so intuitively the corner edges are more
likely to be tripped because there's
just sort of information passing to them
truth has kind of fewer disjoint routes
going to them than somewhere in the
middle so is there any connection of
percolation there is actually some of
our some of our arguments are inspired
by percolation arguments we could we
really wanted to use some deep
percolation theorem black box to prove
some cool theorem couldn't get it to
work but indeed what we wind up doing I
mean so the connection would be you know
when it when an edge is noisy you know
that would be like you know deleting an
edge from the grid and an infinite
community yeah and so you care a lot
about connected components you know in
the in the open graph and percolation
and that's going to be a lot what our
proofs look like here so we don't have
an interesting formal connection I do
think there might be one and certainly
you know they're reminiscent of each
other I completely agree other questions
that's a good question you could imagine
actually proving an information
theoretic lower bounds saying that the
so this is sort of a more fine-grained
measure so this isn't just sort of
average error this is average error
pixel by pixel and I'm going to show you
some lower bounds on the on the best
error possible but it's not going to be
pixel by pixel
it'll just be sort of on average you
could imagine stronger lower bounds that
even talked about which parts of the
graph you're most likely to get wrong we
haven't done that but I think that would
be interesting so bounded genus this
tends to work well too overall probably
become uniform I see I see
you'd sort of expect so but we didn't
run the experiment on it but I would
expect so I mean the algorithms are all
kind of very symmetric so I would think
so other questions
tonight I'll show you the algorithm will
not actually exploit the grid okay so in
that sense you'd expect the results to
be okay
good so we want in theory to explain
this right so as soon as the grid is
behaving in a much better fashion than
the path and then what are the graphs do
well how do we prove we're doing well in
the grid and so on so this suggests we
need a definition to distinguish between
bad graphs like the path and potentially
good graphs like the grid okay so this I
think is the definition probably any of
you would have written down also
so just qualitatively getting at what
are the good grass or the bad graph so
we're going to say that approximate
recovery is possible in a family of
graphs if there exists some algorithm
not necessarily efficient so that the
expected error goes to 0 with the noise
rates
okay so f of P here is the fraction of
vertices you get wrong and you want that
going to zero as P goes to zero so to be
precise what are the quantifiers the
quantifiers are for every P greater than
0 there exists and then not so the per
all graphs and the family with more than
n not vertices the expected area of your
algorithm is at most F of P times n and
that's exactly what we did not have in
the path you can take the noise
probability P as low as you want I can
find a big enough graph you know like
with one over P squared vertices so that
your expected areas that leads point to
5 times n ok so this is failed by the
path hopefully it's met by other graphs
now so this is just qualitatively so
this is kind of a binary thing you
dissatisfied this or you don't of course
when you do satisfy this you want to get
greedy okay so maybe you want to not
just you know have an algorithm but a
polynomial time algorithm and maybe you
also want to pin down exactly what is
the best possible error rate as a
function of P you'd like the smallest
function at P possible okay so those are
the kinds of statements interested in
making questions at this point
so the theorems in this talk are about
exactly sort of this question these two
questions was it clear yeah and that's
exactly where we're going
exactly but so for a given family of
graphs infinite families of graphs you
know it's either gonna have this
property or is it now you know we want
our theorems to more illuminate what is
the structure which drives when this is
true and so that's the theorems we
aspire to it we don't want a graph
family which sort of accidentally
satisfies this condition in some sense
other questions
okay some type of the algorithm all the
results are about exactly the same
algorithm and this is this is where the
connection the correlation clustering
comes in so our algorithm is simply
going to be computes the binary labeling
of the vertices that minimizes the
disagreement with the input right so the
input gives you a suggestion for each
edge whether the end point should be
different or the same and you want to
take as much as that advice as possible
so you incur an error so the algorithm
thinks of its objective function is it
incurs an error whenever it assigns two
end points of the plus edge different
colors or the two end points of a minus
edge the same color and so it wants to
minimize the number of errors of this
type over all possible binary labels
okay so this is exactly the correlation
clustering problem restricted to two
clusters or if you're coming from
machine learning background this is just
a suitable maximum likelihood estimator
okay for the sort of background
generative model you can have a couple
complaints about this algorithm so one
complete complaint would be about
computational efficiency and indeed that
scent be hard to solve correlation
clustering in general the good news is
there are some interesting cases where
you can actually solve this problem
exactly in polynomial time in particular
planar graphs and bounded genus graphs
using matching techniques you actually
can solve this exactly so that's nice
beyond that it is np-hard
it's just a heuristic so we're using the
edges just because it's what we've got
and so all of the analysis work is
showing that if you do good on the edges
you do good on the vertices but as we
saw in the path and in general that's
not true but the hope will be for other
graphs doing well on the edges implies
that you do well on the vertices that's
Britax with only one it's got to be one
to the air that's where that's true and
they're going to be a high degree it
somehow has a lot of information in the
immediate neighborhood about what it is
if you just take the majority you start
doing well with high degree vertices so
I take your point but it's not clear
it's an obstacle to to this heuristic
yeah okay so Paula no time and planar
graphs not in general the other thing
you might complain about is I mean it's
sort of solving the wrong objective and
this is kind of what Sampath was getting
at right so you know this is a maximum
likelihood estimator so it's maximizing
probability of the ground truth given
the data but actually that wasn't our
objective function objective function
was to minimize the expected hamming
error okay which is different it's
different than maximizing the likelihood
so in particular if you wanted to be
information theoretic optimal it would
be an algorithm called marginal
inference where you actually sort of
compute the posterior over what the
ground truth might be given what you've
seen given the data and then you do each
pixel independently with respect to that
posterior so that would be optimal this
in some sense is an even heavier
machinery algorithm so while correlation
clustering has the flavor of an np-hard
problem marginal inference has the
flavor of a Sharpie hard problem okay so
this is a some sense an easier is a
heuristic that's a stand-in for marginal
inference so the issue of being of
course you know you you're not going to
get information theoretic optimal in
general for this algorithm but as we'll
see in interesting cases you do get to
within an information theoretic lower
bound up to a constant factor okay so it
seems like you don't lose much from this
heuristic compared to the information
theoretic optimal solution so this will
always be the algorithm they will look
at three cases this is always the
algorithm just minimize disagreement
with the input
lately so I mean the I mean the expected
hamming error will be at most a constant
times the minimum possible for any
algorithm where the constant is
independent of P and yeah I mean the
edges we're just getting optimal with
respect to the data yeah so that's right
so the Delta function is really about
classification here it's about the
vertices our algorithm is using the
edges but the objective is about the
vertices edges were consistent with each
other right so that that's sort of
consistent sort of reverse engineering a
set of edge labels which are mutually
consistent that's basically the same as
computing absolutely that's really the
main one we care about the vertices we
don't care about the edges so the
algorithm is correlation clustering but
the way we evaluate the quality of the
algorithm is different all right so let
me tell you a little bit about our
results and how we prove them so let me
just give you a really simple lemma but
we use it in all of our positive results
we call it the flipping lemma the
flipping one is about bad sits so what's
a bad set okay so you had imagine you
have your ground truth your algorithm
output some labeling okay they got some
of it's got some of the vertices
correctly got some of them incorrect
imagine you just deleted all of the
vertices that were correct from the
graph
leaving you know shattering the graph
into these connected components of
vertices you got entirely wrong those
connected components are the bad sets
okay so put differently it's a maximal
connected sub graph of entirely
mislabeled vertices everything in here
is wrong with respect to the ground
truth that's a bad set okay so what is
the flipping these concern us right if
you have a big bad set it means you have
lots of hamming error so we want to say
these are unlikely to occur okay so if
that's bad what can we say about it
who's the culprit well it's got to be
some corrupted edges right that must be
why our algorithm screwed up the
labeling on s
and indeed whenever you have a bad set
it must be the case that at least half
of the boundary were corrupted so you
flip that probability at least half of
the boundary edges why is that true well
two simple reasons so first of all and
this is where we use the fact we're you
know really optimizing the correlation
clustering objective you know why did
our algorithm label s the way it did
okay well our algorithm certainly thinks
with respect to the data it's getting at
least half of these edges correct why if
it was getting less than 50% of the
edges correct you could just toggle the
label of everybody in s that changes
nothing about edges in here or edges in
here but if you toggle everybody's label
in S it toggles the status of every edge
between the two so if previously more
than half of these you were getting
wrong now half of them you're going to
be getting right with the input so the
algorithm for any set s by virtue of
being optimal thinks it's getting at
least half of the boundary edges labeled
correctly on the other hand this is a
maximal subset of incorrectly labeled
nodes these are all wrong all of these
neighbors are correctly labeled with
respect to the ground truth so with
respect to the ground truth the
algorithms literally getting every
single one of these edges incorrect
every single one of these edges has the
opposite parity and our algorithms
labeling compared to in the ground truth
label so the only way these two things
can be consistent is if at least half of
these edges were corrupted that's the
only way these can be reconciled
okay so bad sets have half of the
boundary being corrupted all right so
which are stopping ten minutes okay okay
let's do this so a couple warmups
okay so proofs of graphs that you can
prove approximate recovery in a single
slide which will lead us to sort of the
the last result I want to talk about
which is about grids and grid light
graphs so just to give you a feel for
this problem and how these arguments
might go this is in some sense a very
easy case expanded graphs ok so D
regular and I'm using the comet oral
definition of expansion so for every set
most half the vertices the boundary size
should be at least a constant factor of
the biggest it could be the biggest
could be being the degree D times the
number of vertices s okay so the claim
is approximate recovery is possible for
any family of D regular expanded graphs
so how would you prove this well you
know think about an algorithms output
think about ground truth in the output
of an algorithm that gives you these bad
sets these are going to the connected
components of mislaid things that are
incorrectly labeled okay the error at
the error incurred by the algorithm is
just the sum of the sizes of the bad
sets okay the bad sets are just the
mislabeled vertices okay so this is what
we want to upper bound well what is the
flipping lemma tell us it says whenever
we have a bad set the only reason that
could have happened is because lots of
corrupted edges on the boundary at least
half of them in an expander we have a
lower bound on how many edges there on
the boundary there's a lot of them okay
so if you had you know 100 vertices that
we're all mislabeled it must be that
there is C times D times 100 edges and
then half of that on the boundary being
corrupted okay so the upshot being is
you know you can charge the area that
you care about on vertices to corrupted
edges up to sort of C over C times D
over to factor okay so what does that
give you so that in something up over
the bad sets you know what's the error
well you can charge it against the
corrupted edges again modulo the C times
D one of these factors of two is because
you only get 1/2 in the flipping lemma
the other factor of two is because we're
double counting corrupted edges
potentially but in any case we know it
would be expect the number of corrupted
edges that's an easy thing that's just P
times the number of edges
it's a D regular graph right so there's
D times n over two edges so that leaves
us with an expected error of 2 P n over
C or C again is the constant in the
expansion condition ok so that's a proof
that you know the algorithm we're
talking about so it shows an expander
grass admit approximate recovery with F
of P linear in P ok questions about that
so it's expanders what's so easy about
expanders as you can charge vertex
errors to edge errors and so that's what
that's what makes that analysis go
so that was simple enough but believe it
or not there's already you know a lot of
stuff we don't understand even about the
expander case it's a correlation
clustering you know expander graphs
aren't planar and correlation clustering
is np-hard on expanders and so we
literally do not know of a polynomial
time recover of non-trivial recovery
result for expanders okay it seems like
you should be able to use semi definite
programming or something like that
that's what's that's what's driven a lot
of the recovery results and say the
stochastic block model but we do not
have any polynomial time algorithm with
a non-trivial error and to you in this
case okay you can also ask about the
error rates let me skip this okay so
there's a you can also you can also hope
to do better than P times n you could
hope to get that optimal which is
probably P to the D over to
so I think you'd need a constant factor
for the complete grasp for an arbitrary
graph yeah almost all of the correlation
clustering literature considers only the
case of a complete graph and that's not
what we're talking about so this result
by domain at all that's the main one
that considers general graphs and they
actually establish a rough equivalence
to multi-cut which suggests the constant
factor algorithms might be out of reach
so I guess I should have said that I
mean to get pong on out time recovery I
think you're unlikely to be able to just
take the now for approximation algorithm
use only the fact that it's an out for
approximation algorithm and prove
something about classification error but
certainly specific algorithms you know
using what they're doing like solving a
semi definite program then I think it is
can it I would hope that you could have
some efficient recovery results like the
fact that you know the input is coming
from the stochastic model if you find
anything that has you know like
non-trivial agreement even from the STP
lips it seems to be hard to do without
actually correlating it somewhat with
the clustering right so you're saying
you could you could have a thin end of
the wedge and sort of propagate from
there potentially I mean that would be
the first way you try I mean that would
be one of the first ways you try to do
it in the spirit of you know old flag
achillion algorithms and that kind of
thing yeah okay okay so second case I'll
just mention very briefly so again just
a family of graphs which you know let me
skip this I don't have time for the good
ok let's move on to the grids ok so rude
end every 10 grades now like I said we
were motivated by vision applications so
it was natural to focus on the grids but
I understand if it bothers you if it
seems like very specific to just be
thinking about grids so let me tell you
actually the two properties of grids
that we're going to use for the analysis
and the theorems will be general for
lots of these grid like graphs so the
first thing we are gonna use play our D
I'm take we're gonna use that there's a
dual graph and we're also going to use
that the dual graph has bounded degree
so in other words in the planar graph
you're given it should be the case that
every face other than the oww
face should have a bounded number of
sides its property one we use with the
grid now we know we need another
property right because the path
satisfies this okay so what we're going
to need is we're going to need a sort of
weak expansion property that the grid
has now the grids not an expander we
know that
what would an expander say it would say
you know if you have s vertices the
number of edges sticking out is linear
in s so the weak version is just going
to say the number of edges sticking out
is lower bounded by at least some
polynomial function of the size of s so
in a grid for example if you have a
subset of the grid with s vertices
there's at least square root of the size
of s edges on the boundary okay so
that's what we use notice in a path this
is totally not true right so I can take
arbitrarily large sub path and I only
get two edges on the boundaries it's not
lower bounded by some polynomial
function of the number of edges inside
okay so these are the two properties we
need for our recovered result but let's
just think about grids specifically so
this is where we get the most sort of
satisfying result so really it's the
same old algorithm correlation
clustering but as I said using matching
you can actually solve it in polynomial
time for planar graphs like grids and
moreover the algorithm gets the
information theoretically optimal you
know minimum expected error okay and the
optimal rate turns out to be P squared
times then okay so the lower bound if
figure the lower bound right it's it's
pretty it's pretty intuitive so you know
the grid is for regular so if you have a
vertex and exactly two out of the four
edges get corrupted
you basically have to guess what that
vertex is okay so for any given vertex
is sort of a P squared probability it's
going to be ambiguous and you have no
idea so that's the intuition behind the
P squared over N lower bound okay so I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
upper bound now
all right so you know I flashed by this
example of graphs that have a large
minimum cuts you know how did that proof
go that proof basically used the fact
that in a graph of the large minimum cut
you can say that almost all cuts have
lots of edges there are very few cuts
that have a small boundary okay
so I need one lemma I forgot about so so
in the expander in the expander graph
case we didn't even use the fact that
edge errors were independent across
edges that actually worked even if you
just gave an adversary a budget of P
times M edges here we're going to need
to use the fact that the edge areas are
independent how do we use them we use
them in the obvious way okay so just for
the Chernoff bound so remember a bad set
is one where a half the boundaries been
corrupted you expect only a p fraction
of the boundary to be corrupted so the
probability that a full half fraction of
that boundary is corrupted is decaying
inverse exponential in the boundary
size.i
the number of edges okay so we're going
to use this this Chernov lemma in the
grid analysis okay all right so for a
given set with a large boundary we know
it's very unlikely to be bad it's
unlikely to cause us a bunch of errors
so then what you have to do is you just
have to show that there aren't too many
cuts around there's an exponential
number of cuts in general you want to
show that almost all of them have a
really big boundary sighs so this
Chernoff bound gives you a really good
upper bound okay so here is let me let
me do this slide this is gonna be buggy
okay but so this here's sort of the
first thought of how you might do this
analysis for graphs okay so we have this
Chernoff bound saying the probability
that a set is bad is inverse exponential
in I the claim is going to be that the
number of connected sub graphs with a
given boundary size I is only
exponential and I okay so and the number
of vertices times 3 to the I okay so the
intuition is this is this is exactly you
know the decay and the probability bound
in our turnip am is strong enough to
cancel out this kind of growth in the
number of cuts with a given boundary
size I okay so here's the proposed proof
so we're counting cuts in the in a
planar graph so we can count cycles in
the dual graph the dual graph to the
grid is basically also a grid
so how many cycles can there be in a
grid well you know you pick the first
vertex and choices for that and it's you
know it's for regular so you have three
choices for each of your next i've
vertices so that gives you n times three
to the I cycles over in the dual and
then cuts with a given boundary size I
in the in the original graph so how do
you use this so now you basically just
do a sort of parameterised Union bound
parameterised by the number of edges in
the boundary okay so we're gonna be
bucketing connected sub graphs
according to their boundary size so in
the grid you can start this summit for
that's gonna be the smallest boundary
size you have to worry about remember
that the error is just the sum of the
sizes of the bad sets so we're just
going to iterate over all of the
possible bad sets all of the connected
subgraph s and we're just going to look
at you know what would be the error if
it was bad and the probability that is
bad this we know about the Chernoff
bound this is inverse exponential and i
so combining that with the only
exponential and i upper bound on the
number of cuts with the given boundary
size i that gives us this NP squared as
desired okay but this isn't actually
correct you see why good exactly so I'm
not actually so the problem is the lemma
I mean ulemas actually just totally
false there's way more connected sub
graphs of the grid that have this size
boundary okay we forgot about for
example sets that look like this a donut
okay so in the dual right so what are
the cycles the correspond to this donut
well it's actually the union of two
disjoint cycles and we didn't count that
we just counted you know connected
cycles in that argument okay and in fact
there gonna be a lot of use there's way
too many of these for that Union bound
argument to actually go through so we
need a little trick so let me tell you
bout the trick and then I'll wrap up so
we're gonna do is going to generalize
the flipping lemma so the flipping limit
remember this is what said that if
you're a bad set then they're half of
the boundary that just have to be bad so
suppose that donut like s is bad we
already know that you know the union of
its two boundaries at least half of the
edges are corrupted so either the outer
boundary or the inner boundary is at
least half corrupted but actually
something stronger is true both the
outer boundary and the inner boundary or
more than half corrupted so why is the
outer boundary half corrupted well you
know previously we were flipping the
label of everything an S now let's flip
the label of everything an S and the
whole okay that's again going to toggle
the status of everything except of
nothing except for the edges on the
outer boundary of s it'll toggle the
status of each of these edges so if we
had an optimal labeling it must be that
at least half of these were thought to
be good by the algorithm and that all of
those edges had to have been corrupted
in the data okay so that's the
generalized flipping lemma which says
the outer boundary has to be half
corrupted and so you know if you incur
if an algorithm incurs errors in a
doughnut-shaped like this set s we just
proved that actually the filled-in
version of the set is itself a bad set
we were already counting the errors from
this filled-in set and that only over
counts the errors from the donut so we
just charge errors in a non filled-in
set too it's filled inversion okay so
now with the sum looks like it's the
same sum as before except when we're
summing over the cuts with a given
boundary size I we only sum over the
over the sets that have no holes okay
that are filled with those really do
correspond the simple cycles over in the
dual and that's what we can't that's
what we have are bounded by n times 3 to
the I ok and that gets the calculation
to go through let me just wrap up
there's still more open questions this
is not exhaustive there's just tons of
things we don't know so first just kind
of you know most closely related to what
I talked about I showed you a non
example a path and three positive
examples expanders graphs is largeman
cut and grid like graphs all of which
have approximate recovery and I would
love to see you know some more general
understanding of what is the comet or
structure that permits these approximate
recovery results ideally it would be
great to have a characterization like
maybe you could say something like you
know you do approximate recovery if and
only if you have a week expansion
condition that would be best case
scenario at the very least you'd hope to
have much more sweeping positive
statements than we do the capture a
bunch of different graph classes with a
common argument as I said you know
computational efficiency results the
only one I showed you was for planar
graphs and we really don't know anything
outside of planar graphs again it seems
like an SDP based approach would be the
the first thing to look
based on its success in the stochastic
block model I mentioned a couple times
that in the paper it's a more general
model where you also get noisy
information about the nodes so I tell
you not just information about the
parity between two end points but I give
you advise that this vertex is a zero
and maybe with 60% probability it really
is a zero but with 40% probability it's
actually a 1 anybody give you some you
know helpful advice about the nodes can
you use that extra information they get
better recovery guarantees and frankly
in our paper we weren't able to do much
we sort of used the edge we sort of used
the edge information and then use the
node information to break ties but
hopefully some of you saw Dylan Foster's
lightning talk on Monday there's some
nice progress on the model with node
node signals by Dylan and also Daniel
Reichman and Karthik Shree Turin that's
just a very recent ok so they have some
pretty sweeping results when you also
have this node information available
Frank and then finally everything has
been just about the binary labeling case
ok everything's a 0 or a 1 if you think
about image segmentation sometimes you
want to know more than just what's the
foreground and what's the background
sometimes you want to break it into you
know possibly more than 2 regions that
would correspond to a larger alphabet
size okay bigger than just 0 1 and we
know literally nothing even for alphabet
size 3 the reason being that the
flipping lemma already breaks down or
it's not obvious what its analog is once
you're beyond the binary case ok so lots
to do happy to talk more for the rest of
the day thanks very much
ten so if an edge detector detector has
a problem at one pixel its might well
have a problem at the next pixel which
sort of vaguely suggest looking at
correlated agree D so the comment was
was you know rightfully complaining
about the the assumption of Independence
so you can we can look at these proofs
and see you know how what did we really
use for the expander result we needed
basically nothing so again even an
adversary with who can corrupt an
arbitrary p fraction of the edges the
analysis goes through for the other ones
we needed the Chernoff bound to talk
about these bad sets so if you had a
kind of correlation where you could
still get turned off like bounds that
should be enough to push everything
through because although all the rest is
just about the graph cutting cutting
counting the cut to different sizes in
the graph
you'll have to labels you have access to
query for two labels on vertices but you
don't want to put it on every label just
there saying like an active learning
kind of setup
yeah yeah we never thought about that
essentially yeah so the question then
could you get sort of a query complexity
which is strictly less than the error
rates you get with no queries yeah it's
an excellent question I have no
intuition about whether you could beat
the yeah right so somehow it's a little
bit I mean so that I would think would I
see so you're saying okay good so rather
than just getting sort of one sample
from a distribution you get sort of
multiple samples yeah that good question
we didn't think about that and you'd
hope you could do better pretty quickly
with multiple samples but we never
thought about it yeah okay so let's take
advantage of the break to ask more
questions and